hi I'm Alex and this is my recipe for
chocolate stuff churro donut you may
have seen churro cones you may have seen
churro bowls but have you seen churro
don't know so this recipe took a little
bit of trial and error and testing to
figure out how to execute but believe me
they're so delicious I still dream of
them so it starts to make these chariots
you're gonna start with a pot two choux
choux pastry so first you to melt down
the butter the water the sugar and salt
and get back to a liquid state and once
that's all melted down while the pot is
still on the heat you're gonna add the
flour then you're gonna start to mix and
you're gonna mix and mix it and mix
until you get like a homogeneous dough
so then we're gonna take the pot off of
the heat and this is because when you
start to incorporate your eggs you don't
want the eggs to cook you just want the
eggs to incorporate into the dough so
once you take it off the heat you're
gonna add the vanilla and then you're
gonna start to incorporate the eggs one
at a time you want to make sure that the
egg it's bullying corporated each time
and believe me your arm is gonna get
tired maybe you need to call in a
reinforcements just takes a lot of
manpower woman power mixing power arm
power oh my god
you can do it I believe in you is a good
workout and you earned your donut till
your choux pastry dough should be all
one like smooth dough and I was taught
that if you pick it up in your spoon you
can flip it over and it should pop down
so so now in order to get our churros
every churro needs to have the classic
churro ridges
I guess I'd call them they're gonna
transfer your dough into a piping bag
with kind of like a storage tip so put
the dough in a circle on a baking sheet
and then you're gonna top that dough
with chocolate chips no we're gonna top
the chocolate with another layer of the
Trobe dough now you want to go a little
bit slow here and make sure that you're
completely covering the chocolate
because if it's exposed it's gonna like
first when you're frying so you just
want to make sure that you're kind of
like going slow enough to seal those
edges up but it's not that hard just go
slow I don't know what makes the donut a
donut but this is a donut because it's
ring shaped with a hole in the middle
so once those are all covered you're
gonna pop these in the freezer to set
this doesn't make your life a whole lot
easier so you can pop them out and throw
them in the fryer so ads are frozen just
take a little knife to release the trout
donut from the baking sheet and then
you're gonna pop that in the oil I'll
fry up really nicely so then you're
gonna transfer these to a rack to make
sure you drain off any of excess oil and
now of course no churro is complete
without cinnamon sugar coating so you're
gonna dip those donuts right into that
delicious cinnamon sugar mixture and
then you're ready to eat you're gonna
want to eat these right away
wow they're hot at least that's what I
recommend so go for it you beating them
all if you want anyways they're
delicious
you should eat them you should make them
you should subscribe to my youtube
channel all of the above
[Music]
[Music]